[inaudible] listening to radio lab radio show from [inaudible].
W.
N. Y. S. E. N. N. P. R. Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab podcast. Oh, does that how it usually works,
do you say the podcast? Yes. No, it just sounded,
sounded so different to different, something just got some sweat.
That's really how we did it. We could try. We could just do this,
do it differently. Let, I'll try to go first. [inaudible] shock. Yeah. Okay.
Do it. Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich from jet. Have him ride. I am,
this is radio lab, the podcast,
and on this podcast we are going to have a conversation. Not,
not an easy conversation. I wouldn't say nope.
It begins really with a difficult question.
Maybe the most difficult question a person can be asked and uh,
asking for us as our producer Sean Cole. Well, this,
this story starts with a Dr. Guy named Joseph Gallo. Hello.
Can you hear me, Joe? Yeah. Okay, great. Yeah, he's a real sweetheart. Actually.
I feel like a celebrity. You're sending a sound person here. Joe's an MD,
but, um,
he's also a professor at Johns Hopkins University in Baltimore and he's been
working on a study that I,
I just frankly find totally fascinating. Let me, yeah, let me,
if I rambled, just stop me. But, so here's the story.
A long time ago in the 1940s and early fifties,
Johns Hopkins launched something called the precursors study and all of these
graduating medical students,
1,337 students signed up between 1948 and 1964.
And every one of them agreed to be poked, prodded, examined, up and down.
You know, their blood pressure, their way asked all these questions, habits,
how much exercise they took. They did a Rorschach ink blot test.
Wow. And what was the point of this study? Well,
originally it was just to pinpoint the precursors to heart disease,
but over time the study went way beyond that and the researchers started asking
all sorts of other questions, questions about to oppression, anxiety,
50 years of the study and the doctors are getting older and older and support
retirement at a certain point. But 15 years ago,
Joe and the other researchers start to ask these doctors about death.
So if you, if you have that paper in front of you, yeah, hang on.
Essentially what they did was they presented the doctors,
many of whom are now in their sixties,
seventies and eighties with the following scenario. Dario was there, it says,
it says, and it goes something like this.
So say you have brain damage or some brain disease that can't be cured.
You can't recognize people, you can't speak understandably.
And um, you're in this condition for a long time. Like your brain dead.
Well you're not brain dead,
but it kind of describes maybe a scenario that's like severe dementia and then
it says, indicate your wishes regarding the use of each of the following medical
procedures. There's a list, 10 CPR, [inaudible] fluids,
major surgery. This is a bunch of them.
So the question they're asking is if like, if,
if I'm in this terrible situation, would I, would I want these things?
Would you agree to have these things done to you if it came down to it? Okay.
So how so what would you say as an example,
you're asking us now and I also put the question to a bunch of people in the
street, or my name's Sean column reported with [inaudible].
Give me words to like, so CPR for example. So your heart stopped CPR.
Would I want CPR? Yes. I want somebody to do that. Yeah, sure. Yes.
Well, yes. It seems like a no brainer. What about mechanical ventilation?
It's a breathing machine. A breathing machine.
You're going to die if you don't get it. Well maybe then. Yes. Yeah. Okay.
Yes. Yeah. Yeah. I wouldn't say don't do it. Yeah. You remember all of them?
Kidney Dialysis, dialysis. Yes.
So a feeding tube? Yes. Yup. Major surgery.
I don't know.
Like a gallbladder operation if we're just talking about the gallbladder. Sure,
yeah. Antibiotics. Yeah, totally. Sure, sure.
Ivy hydration. Yes. You would want all that? Yeah. Yes,
yes and yes. That's what most people say they want most everything. I mean,
maybe not some of the super invasive stuff, but generally, yes. Okay.
On the other hand, you asked the doctors what they want, same situation,
brain dead or brain injured, whatever. Do they want CPR?
90% say no. They would not want CPR. Really.
90% no. Yeah,
I'm I and I asked a bunch of doctors at a vascular health conference here in New
York, the following medical procedure, they said the same thing. A CPR,
no CPR, no, no CPR,
no CPR and almost 80% ventilation.
No or dialysis? Definitely not. Oh No, no.
80% would not want surgery. No.
80% will not want invasive testing. Oh No.
I'm almost 80% wouldn't want a feeding tube. What were blood products?
No antibiotics. 60% say no.
Ivy hydration, about 60% say no. They don't probably know.
And then pain medicine is the one that's a bit different.
The actual item on the survey reads, would you opt for pain medications?
Even if they dull the consciousness and indirectly shorten my life, they are.
80% of them say yes, yes, yes,
absolutely, yes. More. Thank you, Lee. Yes. Yes. Medication. Yes.
So pain medication is all all they want for the most part. Yeah.
Why would there be such a big gap between the,
between doctors and patients in terms of how
they wanted it in their life? Yeah.
Well, hi, is that you? It's me. Great to meet you, Sean.
How are you doing?
It started to become clear to me when I talked with Ken Murray,
he's also a doctor and you're in your doctor White's here.
I thought I'd impress you.
I met up with him at a hospital and in Los Angeles he's written a bunch of
articles now about how doctors want to die. Exact question was asked.
So I asked him like, why is there this difference, you know,
particularly with something like CPR,
what is it that doctors know that we're not aware of? Well,
we,
we know that CPR is basically pretty terrible as an intervention.
It basically doesn't work very well and um,
and people just don't believe that.
They just can't believe it and for very good. The reason why [inaudible]
there was a study done in 1996 about how many people survive CPR intervention on
er, Chicago hope rescue nine one one is 96.
Those are hot shows. Then,
and so the researcher watched all of these medical dramas and recorded,
the result was, come on, you can do it. Come back to a stock, do it.
Come on dude. [inaudible] book.
And the answer was 75% of the time people,
okay, get the oxygen easy or revived easy bus.
It works. 75% of the time, easy breaths.
The actual number is more like eight,
8% roughly 8% survive to at least a month.
And, and in fact it's worse than that. Here's how that 8% breaks down.
Oh, when you actually break it down,
there was a fellow who did a study in 2010 he looked at 95,000 cases.
Uh, actually more than that.
And I think it was all the cases in Japan that year.
And what he found was that all about 3% had what you would call a good outcome
that is returned to a meaningful quality of life.
You and me sitting here talking and eating sandwiches,
exactly about the same number,
3% or so ended up in a chronic vegetative state,
not quite brain dead, but pretty close.
And the final 2% or in some sort of intermediate level,
not good, but they weren't calm, atos, everybody else was dead.
That's the reality of it. And, and we physicians,
we know that we've actually done CPR.
We have actually laid hands on the chest.
Here's something I didn't know. Ken says it when when you do CPR,
you often end up cracking the person's ribs and you had that according to Ken is
kind of mild in terms of some of the things
that doctors put patients through.
I think a lot of times we're doing things to people that we wouldn't do to a
terrorist. Is that true or is that overstated?
I'm not kidding. Like what kinds of things? Well,
paralyzing somebody so that you cannot move,
which you generally have to do when you put a person on a ventilator,
a breathing machine, a respirator.
When you put somebody on one of these machines, it breathes for you.
But the problem is you will fight it because you'll have your own rhythm.
So what happens is you have a person that is fighting, fighting, fighting,
fighting, and, and you can't get air in. And out of them.
So you paralyzed them
so they stopped fighting. You know, they can't move,
but it doesn't mean they're asleep. They're not asleep.
They are completely helpless. Um,
and yet they're aware of everything that's going on around them. Um,
so it sounds nightmarish actually. Yeah. Yeah.
Ken took me through a bunch of different situations from congestive heart
failure to lung disease and pancreatic cancer where he feels basically that the,
the treatment is like worse than the actual disease of what you have.
It may be prolonging, but not for very long.
And the life that you have left is misery.
Right, right. In fact, Ken says the colleagues of his other doctors,
they'll turn to me in the ICU and they say, if you find me like this, kill me.
And they're not kidding.
He says there were doctors who were medallions with the words no code stamped on
them, which just means don't resuscitate me.
He's even seen tattoos that say no code.
Okay. Can I talk to you now? Yes.
Do you have any idea? Come on. Turn that off. Hey John,
can I just record for one second? Yeah.
Because while you were reporting this piece,
a very strange coincidence happened to me.
I was visiting my dad and a after dinner one night he sits me down and he says,
I have something important I want to tell you. Yes,
I've signed an advanced directive. Basically means if I end up in the hospital,
a terminally ill or something, I don't want a lot of medical stuff done to me.
I had not told him about your story at all. Really? Yeah.
So it was just out of the blue and he shows you a piece of paper or no,
not then, but I uh,
just saw him a couple of days ago and asked him to read it to me because I
hadn't actually seen it yet. What is, what does it say?
Yes,
I did directed medical care be withheld or withdrawn and that I be permitted to
die naturally with only the administration of medications. Right.
I can just give a little bit that paragraph.
I authorize the withholding of artificially provided food,
intravenous fluids and other nourishments.
If I cannot give directions regarding my medical care and tend to my family and
physicians honor this declaration as the final expression of my legal right to
refuse medical care and I accept the consequences of that refusal. Yeah. Huh.
Okay. So pain medication is all you really want? Yeah.
To keep me comfortable. So th, uh,
was the same as like the baby's crying. So you, it sounds like,
why wouldn't you want, um, artificially provided food,
intravenous fluids or other nourishment? That's my choice. I know,
but that doesn't sound like it's that much of, um, intervention really.
It is an intervention to sustain life on necessarily.
If I should ever have a terminal condition,
would you want CPR done? If I have a choice to answer, there's no hmm.
But wouldn't you want Monterey to be in a position where we can make the
decision? I mean, uh,
what if you conflict like that?
She, she feels one way. I feel another, yeah, he told me,
this is one of the worries that doctors have, uh, that you know,
they'll have talked to the patient or the patient's family explained the
situation carefully and everyone's agreed, no more interventions. But then,
uh, a random family member will just show up, you know, like a cousin or a,
an a strange son or daughter maybe carrying a lot of guilt and they're like, no,
doc, you have to do whatever it takes. Right?
At the end of the day,
I give the option to the patient and to the family to make a decision.
That's what I have to do.
Except in this case and the patient is him with a t v by having this means we
have to honor this, right? We can't, we can't have our own feelings about it.
You're going to have your own feelings, but you still have to honor this.
But it is the thing that gives me pause is that, I mean, you're a,
you're a doctor.
Your job is to prolong life and to sustain life and you choose not to when it
comes to your own life. Nobody has said, my job is to sustain life.
My job is to sustain life. One, it is possible.
It is not sustained life run its few time and if you're going to sustain my life
on a respirator, I don't want it. That kind of life.
I do not want
[inaudible]
more than anything.
That thing he wanted to make sure of is that he does not die in a hospital.
He definitely does not want to die at the place where he works. That's,
that's something that came up a few times among the doctors at the conference
that I went,
no, I think I don't want to die in a hospital bed.
This is Tim Ryan, a resident at Cleveland Clinic. Why not? A?
Because I see patients and patients' families, uh,
suffer tremendously and I think we do a poor job of communicating futility
today.
I don't know how to communicate that effectively.
I don't know how to do it better.
It's a difficult thing to bring up to the family. You know, how,
how do you tell them your grandfather is not going to get better?
We can keep them alive for a few weeks or a few months,
but he's probably gonna have a tracheostomy and a feeding tube,
a catheter in his bladder and then he'll get bed sores and slowly deteriorate.
I think we can focus on, you know,
extending a life that has some quality so they can interact with their family.
But you know, once, once that's gone,
I don't know that we do much benefit. Sounded Great. That was perfect.
Why didn't say that? Um, I dunno.
You have to have a sense that people want to hear that no one would want to hear
that. I, they would want [inaudible] but it's a little bit presumptuous.
You know, you, I mean you can't tell someone not to hope.
You can't pressure them to just let go of their loved one and obviously you
can't refuse to provide care.
Do you know the, um, there is one thing that struck me that talking to my dad,
there's a question that patients will sometimes ask that can be a kind of bridge
between doctors and patients. Um, very often he says,
when people are in the middle of this decision spending,
they'll turn to him and they'll say, doc,
what would you do if this was your mother or father, you know? And he says,
when they ask the question that way,
it creates an entirely different conversation. He can say,
here's what I would honestly do. Or in fact, and I did not know this, do this.
Here's what I actually did.
It happened with my parents when my father fell ill and developed complications
as a result of the fall.
He says he called the doctor and told him no more medical interventions and he
ended up dying comfortably. Same thing happened with my mother.
I had discussed it with my mother and my father when they were not sick.
This was a plan.
I can tell you in 9% of the patients that I see,
such planning doesn't happen.
I had a habit for most of my career when I'd have a new patient come in,
particularly over the age of 50, I'd ask them, hey, how do you want to die?
And this is Ken Murray again. You know, a lot of, a lot of them, you know,
you give me kind of a funny look,
that's an odd question for a doctor to be asking me. I said, what? You know,
it's the one thing I'm,
we can be sure of that it's going to happen eventually and a,
I want to make sure it happens the way you want. And um, and so people,
you know, the typical answer is wad like to die in my sleep. You know,
painlessly
the fastest way was out any pain, peaceful without pain and was friends,
which is how most people answer the question.
Doctors and non doctor with the least amount of pain and not drag it on swiftly
and painlessly. But what is that mean? What,
what actually is that? That's usually, um,
a attack
or stroke, something of that nature that happens just like that.
And you're gone.
And that's what we and our doctors are essentially doing everything in our power
to avoid. So like when you ask people in the abstract,
they're saying, how do I want to die peacefully? I want to die peacefully.
I wanna die in my sleep and everything like that.
But when you ask them the specifics,
you hear no pound on my chest, stick a tube down my throat.
So it's this paradox of sounds. Do you like a paradox? But think about it,
right?
It is. It could be if it's so,
so healthy to do both. Even at the same time,
it's healthy to want to stay and it's healthy to,
to know how to be ready to go.
I was listening to a fresh air sort of retake and they had Maurice Sendak on the
air who died not too long ago before he died. He was on fresh air.
It's an amazing interview. Yeah.
And Terry Gross was talking to him and he's sitting there in his Connecticut
House looking out the window at a tree and he says, ah, to Terry. I,
I am so in love with the tree.
And the beauty of it and my chance to keep it company just a little while longer
and I want to stay and every extra day I get is a day that's precious to me and
makes me want to stay even harder. Buddy says to Terry,
I am ready to go when it's time I've made myself ready.
And that,
that compromise you make with yourself to love it with your whole soul and yet
at the same time say,
I'll know when it's over and I'm composed enough and prepared enough to take my
exit. That's, that's what a good death is.
[inaudible]
uh, thank you Sean. Cool. You're welcome. This is Sean calls. I mean,
it's not his last appearance yet,
but this is the last time he's on our full paycheck. Yeah.
Going off to host many things and be recorded in other places. Yes.
It is a kind of death. Really. Yes. Nothing good that though.
It means Sean that you get that you come back here regular. Well,
I will haunt you all.
You better special thanks to everybody at the UV symposium on vascular health
and to our doctors in this case. Uh, Joe Gallo and Ken Murray.
I am Jan Apple. I'm Rod. I'm Robert Krulwich. Thank you guys for listening.